don't think you have to say brunette if you wanna try being blonde
simply because like
of my personal opinions about blonde as it pertains to the white beauty standard
because I found blonde okay
even if you can have criticisms or have like
observances about the beauty standard
doesn't mean that you also don't like
adhere to them because they are the standard practice of the day
and I just like changing my hair color cause it's fun
but you will notice
or at least like I've noticed as somebody who's changed my hair color a lot
um and other people can corroborate in the comments
if you've had a similar experience
you get more male attention with blonde hair
you just do so that's some food for thought